Critics and audiences agree that Aquaman feels
like a breath of fresh air after drowning
in DC's murkier efforts.
It's a light, funny adventure film anchored
by two charming leads and buoyed by eye-popping
visuals.
But a vessel this large can only turn its
rudder so fast, and it's bound to have a few
barnacles still clinging to its hull.
Prepare for spoilers, and continue full speed
ahead to the three best and three worst things
about Aquaman.
Batman and Superman have some pretty iconic
bad guys always giving them grief.
By contrast, Aquaman...doesn't.
The movie introduces perhaps the two most
significant villains from the pages of Aquaman
comics, Black Manta and Ocean Master.
Both of them are okay, but the story suffers
slightly from having two separate antagonists
diluting the story's central conflict.
It's a problem all too common to superhero
movies.
At least we know we'll get more of Black Manta
and that big laser-shooting helmet of his
in the inevitable sequel...
Jason Momoa was a highlight of Justice League,
and fans have been looking forward to more
of his likeable dirtbag embodiment of Arthur
Curry.
Not only does the Aquaman solo movie live
up to its potential as a Momoa vehicle, it
supports him with one of the best casts yet
assembled for the DCEU.
It's an eclectic ensemble with some surprising
cameos, but each gets a moment to shine and,
unlike some of the more convoluted comic movies
in recent memory, everyone's clearly on the
same page about what kind of strange adventure
they're on.
Momoa continues his schtick as the buff, waterlogged
barfly with a heart of gold, but being the
center of attention allows him to add new
layers to the character.
He lets Arthur's self-doubt bubble to the
surface in his most vulnerable moments, making
him endearing without sacrificing any of his
rowdy charm.
Meanwhile, Amber Heard successfully leads
alongside him as Mera with a perfect balance
of fearsome focus and wide-eyed wonder.
From her scene wandering Sicily with Arthur
to her battle through the city, Heard makes
Mera a true standout.
Justice League formally introduced audiences
to Aquaman, but only had time for a brief
exploration of his Atlantean origins.
Mera appeared in one sequence, in which Arthur
attempted to protect a Mother Box from Steppenwolf.
Arthur expressed bitterness over being "abandoned"
by his mother, Queen Atlanna, and held her
neglect against the people of Atlantis.
The Arthur we catch up with in Aquaman is
less angry at his mother — he's aware that
she was forced to return to the sea — and
learns that she was sacrificed to a monster-filled
place called the Trench for the crime of having
a half-breed son, filling him with grief and
guilt.
The movie more or less has to undo the motivations
established in Justice League in order to
get his character arc moving in the right
direction.
There's also a change in how Atlanteans communicate
— it seemed in Justice League that Arthur
and Mera could only talk inside an air bubble,
but Aquaman has its characters speak freely
even when submerged.
It makes sense that a movie set mostly underwater
would choose not to complicate its characters'
ability to talk to each other in this way,
but it raises the question of why Justice
League introduced such a clunky conceit in
the first place.
Fans might be slightly annoyed at Aquaman's
contradictions of established DCEU lore, but
this actually becomes one of its strongest
assets: the movie is completely unburdened
by connections to other movies, either past
or present.
Where Batman v Superman: Dawn of Justice nearly
drowned in set-ups and introductions designed
to pay off in future installments, Aquaman
floats free, unencumbered by the sort of franchise-minded
filmmaking that has sunk other comic book
movies.
Aside from briefly mentioning Arthur's battle
with Steppenwolf, Aquaman contains no references
to any other DC characters not involved in
its hero's journey.
No secret Lexcorp files, no foreshadowing
of cataclysmic events to come.
It's just a straight-ahead adventure story
about Aquaman and his friends and enemies.
It is, in fact, a perfect jumping-on point
for newcomers to the DC Universe — something
Warner Bros. sorely needs after the convoluted
webs of its predecessors proved off-putting
for audiences and critics.
Regardless of how well Aquaman plays to its
strengths, it's still going to be the story
of a would-be king who talks to fish and does
battle with merpeople.
It will probably never reach the universal
acclaim of something like The Dark Knight,
a movie based on comic books and treated as
a hard-hitting police drama.
Arthur Curry's adventures will simply never
have the same potential for crossover appeal.
But here's the thing about a movie that leans
all the way into its own comic book silliness:
it's exactly what DC Films needs right now.
While some discerning theatergoers might be
turned off by such a goofy outing as Aquaman,
it serves as the perfect antidote to the grim
self-seriousness of movies like Batman v Superman.
"Tell me…
Do you bleed?"
We've watched Superman die and we've seen
Batman live long enough to become to villain.
Even Wonder Woman's solo story didn't have
much time for levity once Diana arrived in
the trenches of World War I. Justice League
had a jarring tonal dissonance, trapped somewhere
between brooding and romping.
"So your genius move is dying.
You really are outta your mind."
"I'm not the one who brought a pitchfork."
But Aquaman is bright, wacky, and seems intent
on doing nothing beyond shooting fun straight
into its viewers' eyeballs.
Arthur's tale is a feel-good story concerned
not with societal ethics or the meaning of
existence, but with his own journey to find
his own place and commit to what he cares
about.
It will never make a shortlist of "Important
Films" or warrant major Oscar consideration,
but it isn't trying to.
It's just fun, and in a year when Marvel slaughtered
half of all life in the universe, that makes
it a welcome dash of lightness and fun.
"Show off.
I coulda just peed on it."